[Applaudissements]
voilà le dernier rempart après avec
schwarzy j'adore mais ne dernière lui
c'est le génie basique et de bien être
alors autebon de michel drucker c'est
beaucoup plus beau compliment
on commence très vite ce 20h45 avec très
vite le 20h45 j'adorerais bien sûr les
24 heures très très vite l'évacuer à 30m
et c'est tout ce qu'il fallait très vite
voir à la télé dans sept des 24 heures
très vite c'est tout ce qu'il fallait
surtout pas rater bien sûr sur la
journée d'hier tu te jeu télé qui a eu
quelques lacunes en italien tu comprends
pourquoi ils l'ont envoyée sur le
paris-dakar et pas où vas tu t'en ou
arrière veulent leur revanche
kevin benavides se lance dans une
opération tutti frutti tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui des belges ont suivi en
direct la première conférence de presse
du nouveau sélectionneur du quinze de
france
ah ouais l'impression que le caméraman
de la fédération n'est pas encore offert
aux points sur 100 m
[Musique]
[Rires]
alexis notre voyant préféré à essayer de
participer à l'émission en échange nos
mamans en scred mais on la grille est
d'instruction achever jeu télé anglaise
on a vu le député qui a passé une nuit
agitée vu son état au parlement et du
quartier galère où c'est nécessaire
le gars est fragile au parlement et
surtout en angleterre toujours j'ai vu
le journaliste anglais qui tient
absolument à passer par la porte pour
promener son chien
alors que franchement il ya la chine
appuie sabia a abondé et petit concept
yann et ses potes le savoir à votre
coiffeur il faut le prendre très mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les feuilles les perdants sont les prix
une bonne image froide main froide
c'est moins bon goal ça vous le savez
c'est impossible de regarder la télé
chaque jour et de sortir en boîte c'est
pour ça qu'on sait dispatcher des rôles
avec jean mi j'ai maté 90 minutes de jeu
et aujourd'hui sont tombés sur un
délinquant qui a été très vilain et qui
veut se faire corriger par les forces de
l'ordre policière avec leurs santiags
les policiers n'avaient pas prévu
selon comme d'habitude ils ont trafiqué
les voix des personnes pour leur
anonymat lorsque là ils ont modifié
celle du policier ça ressemble à une
voix qu'on connaît bien on connaît
certainement du monde en commun mais pas
on était professionnellement d'engels
goethe économie importés et puis
derrière la tasse ainsi que du trés
personnes
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un que je m'associe
précédents halo les secours sur s'évite
un pompier dans les symptômes de son ami
à un individu il prend des pincettes en
fait on le sait le boulot et bonjour les
pompiers ou dessus de 23 kg niveau de
l'arrêt du bus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un truc comme ça avec mon papa
voilà un bon il ya un ami à moi même me
revois qui avait un bouton et donc mon
père lui et il est très serré aux
perruques ces îlots prendre des faits
mais ce bouton et d où il est dans la
raie des fesses ou dans la nuit c'est
vrai il est comme ça un chameau ined
donc voilà donc ça c'est rester voilée
depuis on en rigole comme des dingues
anecdotes de merde merci il était au
final son taux dans la nuit mais revenu
l'anus edwards est faisant quoi l'anus
et dans l'arène je vais y aller moi
aujourd'hui j'ai regardé tous les jt
ocean totalement le jt d'une région à
vous de la retrouver cinq top départ
l'animateur attention je m'étends du
nord de la banlieue parisienne aux
plages de la baie de somme j'ai une
bassin de population abritant quasiment
2 millions de personnes gées fusionner
dans le nord pas de calais avec le nord
pas de calais pour m'amener au de france
depuis deux ans je suis je suis je suis
la capitale et amiens a pas qu'à la
région pas la préfecture de la mer noire
[Applaudissements]
les picards et on embrasse également le
magasin tous les magasins arras et
surgelés et on embrasse le captain igloo
france 3 picardie donc l'animateur est
très proche de sa journaliste tu sens
que c'est une vraie famille françois
picard ni doivent être amis sur facebook
et tutti quanti où tu parles italiani
goudé mais le jazz vous êtes les
bienvenus si vous aimez la musique vous
êtes les bienvenus et surtout elle est
super moi c'est mon coup de coeur du
jour ça va très bien merci beaucoup
merci en se fiant sera dans quelques
capitales
sur bfm sur le présentateur de la
matinale a voulu savoir pourquoi ça
reporter n'est pas en province comme
prévu sur le lieu est d'ailleurs
première question pourquoi n'êtes vous
pas dans l' usine pour que l'on voit les
coulisses de cette entreprise oui mais
alors qu'est ce qui a poussé des
transporteurs de dfm sans faille à ne
pas s'y rendre elle couvrait l'évènement
plus pertinents elle n'approuvait pas la
ligne éditoriale est pas parce que j'ai
plus épineux parce que j'avais envie de
passer la nuit à paris christophe tu as
deviné quel jour de la semaine la rédac
du 13 heures de jean pierre pernaut a
laissé tourner la clim au bureau alors
mesdames et messieurs bonjour non météo
toujours aussi détestable ça ne se calme
pas et regardez les prévisions et galère
je suis dans le député européen yannick
jadot tu la regardes elle a du mal à
cacher sa joie quand un amendement est
signé ça fait pour plein de choses à
vous allez le voir il est vraiment un
foyer nicole et enfin l'oscar 2018 de la
mauvaise foi est attribué à laurent
wauquiez invité ce matin chez jean
jacques bourdin
jauzion des demandes d'asile non
monsieur bourdin toutes les catégories
doute augmenter l'immigration économique
regroupement familial non étudiants
regroupement familial savez c'est
monsieur cependant attendez je veux bien
précis je n'ai pas dire au groupement
fashola petit jeu on adore jouer et les
gens qui sont ici sont des joueurs sans
match de sa vie pour marquer ça va bien
mais bien camille grave de dire oui
c'est même la cami oui oui ce serait pas
acquis ma préférée non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est énorme ça c'est le
meilleur passage du monde ferretti
je sais pas trop donc j'aime bien
castaldi mais j'aime bien comment il
s'appelle c'est richard bégin ciel bas
vous aimez vous aimez la bernard montiel
moi j'aime bien et castaldi aussi oui
d'accord - peut-être et jean michel
hunault michel je connais pas trop
laisser plus de temps avant quelques
jean-michel tout à fait deux ans de
carrière j'avais 7 ans quelle émission
sur ces huit noms on est sur vidéo gag
débardage vous donne mon avenir si
m'arrêter je dois vous êtes très sympa
non merci vous savez comment je
m'appelle oui oui à gérer je vous offre
une paire de chaussettes c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau mais william leymergie
j'étais dans la phase de nantes
alors on a on devait jouer mon cas on va
faire jouer en multi ah ouais t'as
raison regardez à la grande salle et
devinez altiste j'ai regardé aujourd'hui
encore la maline attention est ce que
j'ai regardé je trouve qu'on va trouver
ce cas d'en haut alors c'est quoi ça
fichaux on sait quoi c'est un bon sens
moral l'objet oh oui à tapis et preppy
programme c'est au programme
[Applaudissements]
je le fais pour les rébus percevez la
ravissante comédienne rim critique est
déjà venu nous voir
il a sorti un livre vous le savez sur
son chat donc le veto de la bande en
parle mais vu la tête de so so n était
pas au courant a été un peu surprise
vous connaissez peut-être reem kherici à
brice réalisatrice eh bien aujourd'hui
c'est à sa chatte que nous allons non
pas 3 cognito du comment le pas de
raison que son collègue puissant que
c'est pas la super bonne ambiance dans
la boîte un diu de commerciaux votubia
cette fois ci en meurthe et moselle pour
une troisième visite dès qu'on l'a
commentée et une louche recevez vous en
parliez benjamin castaldi dans top gear
et en l'écoutant l'interview de benji on
a tous versé notre larmichette il a eu
des moments durs quand même bagage à
main surtout quand il raconte ses
expériences avec ses voitures
[Musique]
et du coup toi aussi tu es devenu fan de
ferrari
ouais alors moi j'en ai eu une c'est
vraiment des voitures de merde quoi mais
tu fais paris-deauville taille peut-être
comme ça tu as mal au plus bas prix qui
pousse à douala moi j'en ai jamais eus
mais oui mais j'aime beaucoup de
voitures voilà le mot qui revient tout
moi ça va se voir citer d'autres
voitures ma cité bien sûr l'opel kadett
qui revient très fort et bien sûr la
skoda à la bim bim renaud paquin quoi
l'alpine renault mène la guitare et j'ai
maté midi en france sur france à 10h50
je comprends pas ces gens qui lancent
les choses pas à l'heure à la télé je
trouve que c'est un menteur
c'est comme le paris-dakar touahri n'y
passent par dacia nom de france une
démarche de saison non mais c'est devenu
olaya pouvait dire que deux régions plus
il ya plus de rennes la plus de règles
en tout cas ça marche bien niveau
audience il faut le dire quand même mais
j'entends la mer sa posture très bien
niveau audience c'est cool pour vincent
ferniot et toute sa bande de gangsters
en revanche on a remarqué un truc niveau
publie en quantité sa baisse un peu on
en année dans millan point tu peux
regarder 2015 première saison la grande
époque
ouais carrément 2016 toujours du monde
dames soigneront un peu mois 2010 est ça
commençait à baisser un peu et ce matin
on est dans le dur externe à les images
voilà va du pape on avait tenu une
battle heroes commentaires de miss
univers 16 août que vous mangez trop de
heurts
sympa dit avant de faire mais arrêter
tout on a le nez marre des tarbes alors
aux mets chauds à tuer le game moment
d'émotion ou pas lolo quand il est à la
bourre pour lancer l'appli tracé bien de
votre retraite
et merci de passer nous voir merci
georges jours oui vive gbagbo
bonjour appelle de fait une des jeans
des est difficile où je suis multi forêt
c'est ce que je vois oui d'armes assez
bien fort merci beaucoup jean louis
[Applaudissements]
alors ils resteront dans l'instant il ya
le dernier rempart avec soir bibine
sakon t'inquiète pas le temps pour le
talent c'est vrai mais bien sûr j'ai
encore des petites choses ça vous dormez
aurait comme seul mâle tutoriel est
offert aux bases et je reste un peu
parce que j'avais le cul tout ça c'est
important pour nous si on t'aime saman
l'amour ça se fait à deux merci papa de
moi ces deux textes et les 12 coups de
midi jean luc reichmann il a dit bonjour
pendant très longtemps alexander
jouer
s
un dîner presque parfait il ya une
candidate qui a un peu trop sécher les
cours de géo à l'école visiblement oui
enfin vous n'allez pas venir ni la
bienvenue dans mon pays préférés c'est
l'afrique alors ça continue dans 56
nord-madame j'ai pris des news de mômes
motus ce matin thierry était surexcité
écoutez bien on entend quelqu'un du
public qui on revient même pas de style
en train de voir cherche encore on ne
dira t on retrouver car ton corps tu
finiras pas retrouvé il ya peu après
l'événement c'était le match du pays
voilà l'arrière tu veux qu'on mette à
touba comme ça oui non oui oui quand tu
sais les droits c'est canal+ en vrai je
[Musique]
regarde c'est pour toi c'est mon parti
avec 1
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'appétit
battu sur penalty par
[Applaudissements]
jean tourner les sifflets le héros de
cette soirée
rapport elle a pu s'arrêter c'est
dommage c'est dommage mais comment faire
quand le var a voulu calmer latics à
certains broglio financier la baby do
financiers sa musique est pour toi ça je
t'aime il aimait fort marri moshiri
voilà si je te fais des cadeaux tee je
t'aime bien alors que tu normal hier
soir du coup n'ont été aussi au parc
c'est quand même l'événement ils ont
battu l'équipe de dijon 8 080 c'est rare
de voir sa part sur les feuilles de paye
de casta et on s'est rendu aux
combattants dans le coup d'envoi ont pu
le couple de supporters qui vont se
marier dans quelques semaines c'est
mignon d'été aux abords du parc des
princes regarder et dont ils s'étaient
eux et on a voulu les faire jouer au
fameux jeu du tu préfères avoue préférer
voir marseille 1 champion pendant les
cinq années à venir ou alors que votre
chéri vous quitte pour quelqu'un de
marseille ok elle apprécie on a aussi
voulu retenter notre test sociologique
demandé aux supporters parisiens un
moule sur les marseillais
puis sur les dijonnais mais comme
d'habitude ces deux salles deux
ambiances
alors un petit bout pour les marseillais
marseillais bonne erre sur rue à cane
cane cane canebière et un petit mot pour
les dijonnais bonne chance
un petit mot pour les supporters de
marseille marseillais sur la cane cane
canebière
un petit mot pour les dijonnais merci
pour un motard dans des logiques dix
jours on pense à la moutarde en à
vérifier mais c'est normal c'est logique
a dit jo tu penses à quoi le premier mot
moutarde
si je te dis dijon tu me dis moutarde si
je vous dis dijon moutarde si je te dis
dijon le premier mot qui vient à
l'esprit maillot direct la mayo disons
[Applaudissements]
donc la boîte à choisir défoncé mais non
tu es fou renard fait notre jeu
rapidement notre jeu sur le maillot le
principe on bande les yeux d'un
supporter parisien et il a vingt
secondes pour enfiler le maillot de
neymar sauf qu'entre temps on le
remplace par un maillot de l'om
6e pour ceux qui connaissent pas c'est
celui avec la petite étoile de la
champion's league juste là on est là ici
c'est paris il allonge des rôles bada
je vous jetez de l'huile disease
maintenant notre reporter clément pour
carrément eu aussi le maillot
marseillais et s'éclate avec les
supporters parisiens interview s'arrête
assez vite
pensez vous que la presse est vraiment
supporter de paris
ça dépend non non je suis pas tarder
attention voici mon préféré valley cette
instruction une véritable trahison il
s'était attaché à notre portail 100
poignardé en plein coeur marseillais
m m t as pas marre au nom patois mais si
j'ai trop calme que les versions
supporters parisiens que c'est ça qu'on
va les embêter
zohra cherche quand jean a vraiment
frustrant dit non dans une frange
antilles ont tellement calmes et des
leçons pour y arriver